and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 42 it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day the
four horsemen beam shout out the like
really out kind of hype about if you got
a very special guest pub G 60
frames-per-second fiasco can Bungie
turnaround destiny - xenoblade
chronicles - and who won 2017 to discuss
so we gonna get right into it I would
introduce a Lord whose content I first
came across new Lord sovereign this
young Lord is one of the bright
up-and-comers in our gaming community
delivers solid content with insightful
commentary in a unique and hilarious way
introducing the host of the potentially
perfect YouTube channel one half of the
hammered boroughs with Lord Steve get
good gaming to us in our hearts into the
realm of the Lord's loving Lord dalabo
are you doing sir I am so good thanks
for having me nice nice so good to have
you maybe like what you're doing out
there appreciate some fun today and of
course we have those usual suspects at
the round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother and the house of the
young wolf mommy
Lord addict how are you doing sir pretty
good man rested Wow like this I don't
work overnight anymore
of course a most technical gaming Lord
fresh off vacation back on the scene
hello the solo game who lives with a
single player selfish experience can't
say he was offline because he was away
Bobby Lord sovereign how are you doing
sir fantastic man I had to be back not
glad to be back in the cold good it was
a nice little hole couple things out in
paradise you go what you go I was in
Puerto Rico I went to see family and
surprise the in-laws so that was good
got a little video that my mother-in-law
started cry when that so it was good
they needed dad my wife needed that home
got to eat a lot of food I didn't need
to be eating but you know man it was it
still there places that are in pretty
decent condition I can't complain about
you know my my family's hometown and my
in-laws they're doing pretty well but
there are the places where it's just not
and rate mmm so I mean yeah people
living in caves and crazy stuff like
that so yeah man it's so it still needs
a lot of work but the Christmas season
in Puerto Rico Puerto Ricans are
notorious for how they celebrate the
holidays they celebrate from
Thanksgiving all the way through to
February stop so no matter the situation
the holiday spirit was in full effect
over there so it was good good good see
the human side and you also had some fun
on this that's good shut up the ladies
off as well
oh she laughed at natty map today and of
course the access game oh the Lord of
combat sports who was a man of his
convictions and demands nothing less
than the premium
periods o.b love it
lord egg are we doing sir we're doing
fantastic anchorman
you know I am war this is true um listen
in speaking of war last night we had
some war out here and Michael he knows
what I'm talking about boxing fun and we
had some UFC fun on a serious note on a
boxing tip what I what I like to say to
all boxes is every match every fight you
have to fight it like it's your last
fight you don't take a safe fight yet
you make a fight you take a fight
there's epic for you mom and in this
case last night you had a proven veteran
decided to take a safe bet and there's
no safe bets in boxing you have Miguel
Cotto Puerto Rican icon going up against
Ally let me tell you something
ally is he's nice it's a nice little
amateur record he's not does he's a New
York bred of a fighter he's not all that
well known all right so everybody going
and thought he was a lame duck well I'll
lead didn't think so I'll eat challenge
his self last night while Cotto didn't
challenge himself and he fought down to
the level of competition and what we saw
was an icon getting his head around no
oh
Cotto Cotto look every bit of 37 years
old while that young buck was over him
like blegh legging like a rainstorm
there were some flashes small flashes
but far between the Puerto Rican icon
you go go away don't come back cuz he
doesn't get to cherry-pick on the way
out you're not Floyd Floyd starts a
trend people think oh I can cherry-pick
- no you can't laugh I challenge any one
of you guys to run in there with Conor
McGregor you're gonna get stretched you
won't get
Treach my friend everybody thinks Oh
Froy picked the easy fight yeah he
picked the easy fight anybody got hit
with that Conor McGregor uppercut
they're gonna go to sleep brother and
also UFC had a wonderful call last night
I really gotta give this over to kognito
because he's going to do it justice good
card I mean I'll be completely honest
with you guys I'll be money to chat
everybody yeah it was it was a good car
overall I was just concerned about the
main event the co-main event and now see
we had jose aldo vs the former champ
force max Holloway the current champ
before four but um yeah it may be time
for for Jose to reconsider what he want
to do cuz ya sabe saw it right oh yeah
sorry it was uh I guess I I think Jose
may still have something for some of the
lesser guys in the division but if
you're hunting for titles you need to
rethink you what you're gonna be doing
because Holloway is is just on another
level he's not there anymore it just
feels like he's not all those at a point
obviously think it's the Conor McGregor
night like after he got it
never never saying never Ben's ever been
yeah like 13 seconds let's see how you
feel later and the main event which was
the young hungry up in Colonel Francis I
could never pronounce his last and gone
over and got ya Overeem the veteran a
seasoned veteran the ring and that boy
I've never seen a knockout so vicious
that after the knockout was somebody
stops moving that you're concerned if
this person is alive I was concerned for
Alistair Overeem I'm like yo is he is
this a fantastic
I am guilty of loving a loved one is on
drugs I'm poor anybody who have not seen
this go to YouTube do whatever you got
to do put in the stresses and Gamboa vs.
Alistair Overeem nah it is rule steering
I've ever seen let me tell you Lord
addict
it brought back flashes like old UFC and
you just like wow and this man was stiff
motionless I've never seen a head whip
back like that I grew it was he got hit
with a lightning bolt in his face I
never thought bangle never seen
something like that yeah so I shall
employ everyone yeah I think steep a
might want to be on the lookout for his
belt right now you better be better be
concerned this guy spread neck gaming
realness on the ILP not telling you what
you want to hear what you need to hear
so before we get into what the Lords are
playing I want to start off with the
young lord de la Pole video gun system
history and of course what led him to
the creation of the potentially perfect
YouTube channel Lord the lab or the
floor is yours tell us how you got
started man so a few months ago my
roommate and I we got together we said
hey what if we made a YouTube channel
and so we looked at the various you know
the things we enjoyed we really sat down
about it and you know what the thing
that we had in common something we could
really do for a long time you know video
games
so it it's actually funny because before
then neither one of us I would really
consider you know hardcore gamerz when
you get into this business when you get
into you know video game coverage you
end up following the news and you end up
caring about this stuff way more than
you thought you would and so it becomes
a passion of yours so you know it's the
the creating the YouTube channel is what
I would say made me a hardcore gamer and
so you know when we started it we were
like yo let's do some instructional
videos and then it turned into let's
make some really funny highlight videos
and then a few weeks ago I started doing
you know the editorial type pieces
because you know I just felt like I had
I had something to say you know about
certain topics and video gaming and
things like that and I I it's still in
its infancy and we're still trying to
figure out you know what exactly you
know is gonna be our groove and
everything like that but it's been such
a ride and I'm having such a blast doing
it yes yeah cool cool so let's talk
about let's talk about like the the
first systems you had from a gaming
perspective like what was the first
console you had so the very first
console I had was a Game Boy Advance I
got it was the bright purple indigo
loved it I loved it at Super Mario World
and then after it's really funny though
because like I was never going to be a
Nintendo kid like my mom like the next
console actually had was a Gamecube and
my mom you know we talked about getting
a Playstation 2 for like the longest
time she went to Best Buy without me
guys told her hey you know this is more
kid-friendly console you know get him
the Gamecube so no how old is the
potentially perfect dalabo is 22 years
within people's age the young the young
lions in the game so you got the young
things with anything he relates to that
thank you bizarre acre man's first
console everything's explained now
okay thank you bears a young buck to
Gale on your lap I'm sorry continue
no no it was just been a Nintendo kid
not by choice but by circumstance I was
really confused when unfortunately to
get a Wii U I actually bought one don't
touch to the Gamecube that's so give me
give me some GameCube games cuz I
actually like the game q what was some
of those subtitle did you really enjoy
it all man see I didn't play any of what
the cool kids were playing I played was
a billy hatcher of beautiful Joe okay
yes just just a really outskirt so if I
mean I had a few of the main titles in
Mario Kart Double Dash sunshine and all
that stuff but I really like the the
niche Capcom games on there now I was a
lot of fun yeah so then after that we
graduated what was the the next kind of
consoles that you kind of if it was
Nintendo if Nintendo made it I got it
nice what was weird though I picked up I
had to buy 3 PlayStation 2s because like
I said that curiosity never went away
from me I always wanted hell in that
place Asian 2/3 PlayStation 2 is to get
one that worked Wow I'm telling you
right I don't know leaves the slims
though the stems never I don't know that
something's wrong to slims but yes I
guess like Sony shipped like all the
broken units to your one location it's
possible so currently as we stand right
now or EVP at four you have a do we have
a switch what are we working with so I
just I just entered my foray into PC
gaming so I'm working on that but I have
switched PlayStation 4 huh still being
in the Wii U every once in a while
because there's no other place like to
play like high quality Smash Bros I
don't like that 3ds smash bros nonsense
yes which folks should be coming
hopefully maybe mayor trade walk that
right today yeah so it's definitely
coming for 2018 so that that's pretty
cool
nice way so that's cool get in the game
and join it we see what you're doing I'm
doing it and appreciate it you mean so
that's always good to see and oh real
quick before we let you go oh as far as
that your history is concerned what are
your top five like gaming franchises
either games or franchises in your own
cuz I know you got a top ten out there
so a little get what I want you to
narrow it to that five branch eise's
though franchise is a little different
so probably five put uncharted 4 Legend
of Zelda and talking as a whole because
they've had some quality issues a few
times but um three tomb raider mmm your
tomb raider kid okay yeah
notice you get three I'll put Smash Bros
up there just because of like the sheer
amount of time you soon to your friends
all that good stuff you know it's just
memories number two yeah gotta get tough
and asking tough I'm gonna put Mario at
number two it's like Super Mario okay
number one I'm going to probably give to
Pokemon just because like I have such a
history with it it's it's ridiculous
brother was drowning in Pokemon cars for
longest clearly what a lot of franchises
period so god I gotta respect the movie
I think it's like on the top five of the
most profitable franchises in gaming
history what's funny is the top five
most profitable franchises in history I
think that's it on three mister three
let's do it yeah so basic shout-out to a
little Oppo for sharing that with us so
we can get into what the Lord's are
plain so let's start out with a lot love
what have you recently been playing with
what's been going on recently oh man see
I have this whole tendency of not
finishing games often his games for
nothing so so I picked up Resident Evil
Revelations 1 & 2 for the switch he's
loving it oh my gosh I feel so bad guys
skipped out on him before second one's
way better the voice acting the first
ones garbage but I had so much fun with
that I'm still messing with Mario I just
picked up everybody's golf as we saw
having a blast with the party game stuff
like that it's just the multiplayer
stuff really really clicks with me so
whoo and shout out shout out to you on
the on the channel for the Resident Evil
Revelations on I want to shout out you
and I get actually send that to a
carboxyl as well he was interested in it
he's a few draw huge revelations fan and
it was cool to see you play and kind of
give it put his through his paces and it
looked it looked really good and it was
something it was a game that I know he
was interested I think Lord addict you
know he's interested in those classic
resident evil so it's good to see those
sports come over to the switch oh yeah I
love anything like they did a really
good job especially in handheld mode
because some for some reason some games
like on the switch and handheld mode
look like someone smeared a thin layer
of Vaseline yes forgiveness which has a
doctor mode that anti-aliasing the Lord
addict what have we been playing this
week nothing but Final Fantasy 10 and
like a splash of vino boy nice nice I
see you call back to the Final Fantasy
way too many hours and a Final Fantasy
10 this week like I probably spent 80
hours this week playing Final Fantasy
[Music]
[Laughter]
to be honest with you I I know I'm only
on the third region but I'm just like I
thought people said this game was hard
oh I mean there's a difference between
being challenged to just have repetitive
stuff like yeah it's like look like
these games are designed for you not to
beat the bosses in the first time which
I almost did I feel like I collide that
people might chat down with me they were
like this dude i beaten this dude on the
first go-around he literally had like
happening to life and I was so
frustrated I couldn't the chat was like
oh he's gonna do it jumping into JRPGs
yes we destiny guys at you know our
portfolio is diverse I'm a DJ RPGs and
most these people in this lots off what
have you been playing now I mean uh yeah
I definitely had that switch with me you
know it's not vacation so nice i I'm
close to 500 moons in Mario I'm at the
end I haven't finished a game haven't
seen credits yet um I don't know how
many have you guys finished it yet I've
never seen a game that people are so
obsessed to collecting collectibles like
I've just like the book like it's not
like there's a new cutscene or anything
the way I mean you have you have a lot a
lot of the moves that are just easy like
dumb stuff you just run into a by
mistake but then you get the harder ones
and it's there platforming challenges
and stuff like that so it's fun together
like it's just you know they're just for
the picking like they have them and then
from what I heard once you see credits
and you go back into the game there's so
much more to do so
open them and they actually has a
challenge behind it like it's the
challenge really opens up after the game
yeah that's what I heard so I'm right at
the end and I'm not gonna spoil where I
am exactly but I looked at it I said oh
this is what they wanted to do with
Mario Galaxy playing that I have been
playing Resident Evil Revelations 1 on
this which I picked it up on the 3ds
when it first came out and I bought the
nub and everything and I was into it for
like a week and I said I don't wanna
replay this like is it a combo deal um
Lord Allah promised off is it if you buy
the physical copy its combo if you buy
on the digital a shop they separate them
so 20 apiece in effort okay and in the
physical the physical combo is 40 yeah
right but I mean you don't even get a
physical copy of the second game it's a
download code talk about that later and
Lord King where have you been what does
this Majesty been playing whoa boy this
has been a fantastic week for me so
since I'm free of destiny now inside you
know the group to play destiny so okay
so me young Chris has been are going at
it in Assassin's Creed if I go live on
mixer a lot so I finished Assassin's
Creed oh yeah I finished it I loved that
game I played so hard in a game I'm
gonna go back I have a lot of other
things to do what you can finish it and
don't see the whole world so that
doesn't even matter that you finished it
it doesn't even matter at all
um so I'm going back to do that but also
I got my shadow of war shadow war I can
see why addict was so addicted to this
game um and there's a lot of parallels
between that and Assassin's Creed and
it's so well done agents of may
him I see why they push back um
crackdown three agents of mayhem if you
can get it I got added the very low
price of twenty bucks it was a great
purchase and it's phenomenal
um I have to pick up art you and me both
have shot a little dizzy bet the lord
dizzy because of all the stuff that i
said that was wrong with it and I've
actually been going to play everything
it's a couple of games that I think that
are going to be when you talk about
analytical year games that I think can
actually win it you know it's pretty
good games but so far I've been just
going through my my switch Mario I was
at the pawn shop and I was there all day
and yeah I was playing America when I
got a lot of what Lord's been playing
them for Xbox I've actually really got
far on Wolfenstein to really enjoying it
all Wolfenstein
there's a part I got to which is shot
the modem he told me like that's at a
halfway point and they I don't want to
spoil it but they've done something to
the it is something that I'd never see
done with a main protagonist what's
supposed to happen
they're like all I can say it's very
very well done a lot of mature things
great story sixty frames per second the
goodness 4k goodness it's beautiful
it's really hard that's another thing
the game is really hard like I played a
game like this difficulty person say
that games really hard I swear I'm gonna
quiet we know a lot attic it may not be
hard for you you you you you excel them
type stuff but I almost say this like it
makes you think and what I like is they
definitely have the stealth mechanic so
you can really go stealthy if you want
you don't have to play balls to the wall
you could get it in really enjoying
Wolfenstein and then arm but a switch I
mean I picked up obviously the Z no
we're gonna talk about that there's a
nobody chronicles enjoy
a little bit and um just kind of messing
with my switchback well I think though
I'm Black Friday I took advantage of a
lot of sales they had on don't laugh I
actually picked up monopoly they had to
sail on a joy what do you mean come on
sue about cuphead I beat that shadow
fast back into chat for coming through
yeah it was just one of them things it's
like on the road I figure I've needed
two extra joy Kahn's
monopoly like ten bucks let's go big
that up so that was it so that's pretty
much it as far as the games this week so
we don't get into poll last week our
poll results are in people have spoken
to the question with the rise of social
media Twitter reddit etc bringing more
attention to gaming industry practices
and giving more direct access to execs
is this good for gaming as a whole the
winner at 55% in a very argumentative
Shantanu love dalabo he was in that one
is the yes exposed bad practices and
execs group so they won in 55 it's
coming in at second place at 25 percent
was the know the issues and personal
attacks are way too overblown group and
coming in third place the very shallow
twenty percent in the poll turnout was
especially de la bocha at the loci box
it was in the I was late
talk to Luka Basu I need pictures of
everything from now on you play cabal to
is on the artist difficulty you could
play it on
challenges I want to see a head-to-head
macho be sitting there coming at me say
no cuz I didn't play it on the hardest
difficulty pounds I gained that you have
played besides cup head there's been on
the hardest difficulty every time you
play a new game I don't want to see any
game you play that's not on the hardest
difficulty from now on that sound like a
challenge my instrument or leo or get
off my back touch your back sir so you
would very intense on that a particular
poll so obviously the group that loves
the being these guys being exposed on
social media and in the execs of stuff
that was the winner which way did you
lean your arm towards that pole oh I
died Pig call him out though that and
shout out the cowboy so he just he was
making a point I think in reference to
he understands the call-out he just
didn't like the personal attack culture
of you know with the execs and stuff
like that so I understood what he was
coming from you know I'm saying it in
that respect so it was good good good
banter good discussion I'm like look I'm
not about attacking people but at the
same time like this is the most I've
seen like ei is burning from all ground
I'm hearing they're getting a lot of
feedback bought a backlash from from UFC
now it's at the other day you like EA is
probably one of the most greedy
companies when it comes to gaming I'm
really starting to think that people
getting fired no this is the kind of
like it was like what 2.3 billion
dollars dropped in stock yeah this is
the kind of backlash that will
completely change it companies motives
they thought they could get away with it
without trying to hide it but what's
what's fun if battlefront would have
been the way it was I feel like no one
would be saying
anything about you know there are other
games but battlefront was so bad now any
boxes we burn this spotlight is on we're
gonna get into that when we get into the
oh no what you call the topics when
especially with all as well yeah it's
like whatever you're doing in your game
now the spotlight is on they should step
back that step back heard them and it's
been an aspect that anything that people
don't like they're gonna like rally
against it and they're gonna expect them
to take that same step back and that's
why you never supposed to take a step
back if you stayed farm and you believe
just a farming your beliefs and just let
it rock out nobody made money now
everything they do for scrutinising and
looked at the hourglass so we go get
into these topics for the roundtable I
discuss so I'm gonna set it off first
and let's talk about pub G back in the
news once again so well it's brought to
our attention I think was like Thursday
I think a Brendon green from a blue hole
studio he came out with announcement and
they asked him about you know what the
expectations were for the Xbox one X and
at that time he made a statement he was
like directly on Xbox one X 60 frames
per second he said the game would
definitely hit that target and he said
last time when the Xbox one s Danny base
model he said he start running about
thirty to forty he said they're
constantly improving it the aim was to
get it to 60 so when that announcement
went out you know surely a lot of the
Xbox fan base and people have Xbox when
X were really praising it
they were excited about the potential
for a pub G to be 60 frames per second
and then the very next day shut out the
player at noon do you came out what a
twit a statement and he just said well
he said a pub G would run at a higher
frames per second on the Xbox one X he
said he wants to clarify that they will
run in 30 frames per second across all
Xbox one devices cuz we're constantly
refining the game exploring options to
increase frames per second but this
early in development were unable to
confirm more now this tweet set the net
on fire and I want to bring this to the
Lord's because I'm right
now there's two you know thoughts going
on right now one is that is the Xbox one
X being held back for the sake of parity
right and you know number one and two
you know is it a legitimate thing that
they could do it and maybe PR got ahold
of him because it was such a quick
turnaround so I'm a passes to the Lord's
I want to get to LA blowing an attic in
X I know I'm curious about you - first I
know what I think I know what solving
kids going the level with a good accent
level what do you feel sir I don't
it's the bass Xbox one is not holding it
back Microsoft is holding it back and
the the idea like I was like to relate
it to the new 3ds and the regular 3ds
Nintendo tried at Nintendo said hey
we're gonna let make sure it runs all
the games and everything is that but
we're gonna give exclusive content
things like that games will run better
whatever ever it's a company waste it's
a company based decision - Xbox wants
everything to run you know across all
the same like I'm sorry stat wise across
everything you know in parody and that's
decision they made they didn't have to
do it
personally I think just let it go just
let the Xbox one and one X you know
dominate that she said it does well you
know I don't I don't think you should be
trying to make it so that everything
runs the same you guys pay five hundred
dollars for a console new to get the
mess out of games give them the best out
of those games that's not right just I I
think it I think that's horrible
now let me let me ask you this question
in reference to parity um do you feel
because let's just say ideally it could
run it right and let's just say because
of marketing or what have you they said
no you know make him retract the
statement whatever do you think it's
unfair so from a competitive of shooter
multiplayer shooter that um you know one
should have a 60 frames-per-second
advantage versus the 30 frames per
second or you feel like hey you know if
the people who bought the Xbox one X
paid for that then they should get the
higher frame rate people do it on PC all
the time nominees I mean these companies
in they're trying to talk about we
wanted to be fair are you kidding me
you're with every one of these consoles
they're doing more and more to make it
more and more like pcs every single
you're giving this list example IQs
reasons to even own consoles anymore
used to be you popping a disc use played
a game you can't even do that anymore
they used to be one of the biggest
advantage of owning the console so now
you're telling me now I'm gonna buy this
iterative console I'm gonna pay for and
it's supposed to be the substantial
upgrade but I still gotta play by the
rules at a base one
that's ridiculous yeah it's pretty
interesting look Lord addict I be doing
this I'm very curious let's go look at
the end of the day like look you buy
this console you first off everyone and
everyone's mom told everyone that stuff
like this would happen so people need to
stop acting surprised take it off you
know regardless what people think you
know we do have certain advantages that
song you know that's on the consoles
that you can have just by buying like
the elite controller but you know at the
end of the day it's like people's
people's performance is the same and
that is the biggest advantage you can
have on PC and you can ask a lot of
people on PCs sometimes it's at a hand
the an extra 30 frames between both
that's salty brother
has that does not have an axe could I
have an opinion because I don't have I
love those said that since I don't have
an X I'm automatically deemed salty
that's what you're saying you can't have
an opinion your kindness kind of came
off a salty but no it's not like why
there's why do you think the pros been
doing it like you know it's whatever
like you can say here sit there like how
many of the fractions have an X compared
to the other we know that it's a bigger
install base what I'm saying is like I
hate where you coming from
and you're coming from the point of what
you have I understand that that's what
I'm saying of course you have a voice
actually your voice base is larger than
mine people with the X represent the
majority when it comes down to it
Microsoft is not going to give unfair
advantages it's just no I get it maybe
they could make lobbies with just X
versus people you do these 1v1 some of
these games you know you're gonna turn
an extremely good player from the X is I
mean on the s is gonna get out shot from
someone on the X because he can't keep
up with the performance of the other
console mm-hmm I mean I see when did you
fall we're talking about these you know
decisions that you know Microsoft has
made to increase parity but haven't they
been talking about adding like mouse and
keyboard functionality of this they
could talk all they want but look at
look at games like gears here this has
you know it's got mouse and keyboard
versus four but it's not ranked they got
social playlists and like at the end of
the day it's like look like you know
games like you know Gears of War
it's third-person so it's a little bit
different but you know this um pub G
start person so right into the day it's
like look you know Sun to these
companies might have a slight advantage
but that's not darties frames to 60
frames that's extreme and advantage
that's not a little bit no but you can
squeeze out an extra ten frames on yours
someone questions so if for the Xbox one
x1 is let's just say it could
theoretically hit 60 right and now it's
being pushed down for two 30 frames per
second do you feel that's you you feel
that doesn't matter because you want on
competitive parity especially something
like that like if you were talking about
sky earn mm-hmm like you know like that
wouldn't matter to me but we talking
about something that you're wanting both
people from every console to play
against each other almost every one V
one scenario you have somewhere on as to
someone on Xtreme advantages over them
because they're long hmm interesting is
this is hot I mean you got you got
people like you know looking David say
that I loaded into destiny faster than
everyone else the day that that is an
extreme advantage that's nothing small
like that's extreme and at the end of
the day they're still gonna be selling
more s's than exes so why that's pretty
much like if you don't have an axe don't
play play play or know that around you
first off the game is already a hardcore
game he's going into this hardcore game
ona s what happened the lobby's an ex
it's an automatic l she's not the Lord
cannot sue in the chat he's saying
because the X 1 X Box 1 X is kind of
mirroring kind of a PC you know mindset
that the PC guys have never complained
when they they have the same situation
where some rigs are only capable of
doing 30 frames per second for a 60
frames per second now that's because
they're used to that
they were Brady we love we got a problem
is it the PC has always been the Wild
West and it will always be the Wild West
you're talking about Chloe and will with
the Xbox and the PlayStation the mindset
the mindset of a player is completely
different I and this is the thing like
Microsoft has always been known for
innovating and pushing things where
people didn't think they should go in
the console space took the hard drive in
the Xbox the Ethernet port and Xbox if
they were the first ones to really take
this step into saying we're gonna give
you a substantially more powerful
iterative console then you know what we
have to do have to take that extra step
and make those lobbies that are only for
60 frames per second just said that he
said dedicated rules for Xbox one access
it's like you know you guys you know I
bought this product this and that but
how much do you think that's gonna hurt
the overall you know franchise a pudgy
it's like some people won't even buy it
because they know they can't compete
with the other platform now someone a
buy a $30 game than a $500 console I
understand that point no King I got you
I said I'm of the mind I moved in mind
if I pay $500 for substantially more
powerful console I want to see utilize
now in single player games thus far when
we talk about Sanskrit we talk about
Mordor shadow war like it doesn't matter
because it's a single-player game you're
not gonna really be affecting anybody
with what you do in the game you can see
the substantial differences it's always
been the issue with these living
open-world like these the destinies that
online multiplayer games where that
parody becomes an issue right and I said
that for me Microsoft needs to take that
extra step and as close as they're
trying to make these the consoles with
these these iterative consoles is close
to they're trying to make it to PC it's
still never going to be exactly the same
so you
you have to take that step and create an
environment where both people who owned
both consoles get the premium experience
for that console it's it's an extra step
you have to take but you know what
console gaming has always been about
doing things that it's away from the
norm of PC gaming it's just different
they have to do it and you know it's are
you gonna be separating for an extent
yeah but you have to give the option
like if I'm on an X and I want to I
should be given the option to play in at
60 frames per second Lobby or that 30
frames per second all my friends are
playing at 3300 with them for a little
bit and I'll come back to this one like
it's something that needs to be creative
period period because then you're gonna
do start devaluing what you're you're
you're exiting you and I find I find it
hard to believe I see Komatsu in the in
the chat like pretty much had that
copy-and-paste [ __ ] going on like I find
it hard to believe that it's not an
issue on PC like I look how many people
go to PC and come back because they
can't mess with a combination of mouse
and keyboard over from controller and
stuff like that he's an issue but what
he means and right but what he means is
that it's so widespread and there's so
much variety in terms of graphics cards
and setups like it's so big that you you
can't really complain we're gonna listen
to you like you know but it's but that's
my point you can't say there's not an
issue on PC just because of are the
forms that you look at like oh is it
that the thing you get on to me come out
to like oh it's some of my friends are
so it it isn't it isn't baxlo I don't
think there's a viable way to address it
why are you in the chat saying I'm solid
thinking looking you up maybe guess like
the majority over the menorahs you know
they're right thank you and I
playerbase it's not what's crazy as I
left the majority to go and become the
minority majority excuse me you're
giving them slippy friends what'd you do
with them sticks be friends like listen
listen listen they said that you can get
out for tea in yours alright um be happy
with that 10 80 40 and then you know see
if y'all can mix it up yeah I could
probably get in there and mix it up and
do really well I don't really think
that's exactly I haven't so what I got a
rig that can play though um listen right
the thing is when I play my game I don't
really like this thing right now the
reason why you don't see me on that
PlayStation and I see you on you tell me
you're gonna jump order stuff like that
you know why my playstation don't turn
on because it just be me and you in a
room when I'm playing my xbox I'm
playing with my friends I have all of
this I have everything that's not the
question the question is where do I want
to play pub G I want to play it on my
xbox how do I want to play pub G I want
to play it to the maximum of my brand
new shiny Ferrari I do not need a Volvo
holding me back sling so these Volvo
drivers is over here telling me to slow
down
excuse me bro if you can't keep up
either get a Ferrari or just stay in
your lane and you got your mind
everybody else's mind said I'm gonna
stay exactly where I am right now these
little crates is gonna stay right here
anyway like I was saying listen they're
gonna do something hey I wish it just
comes out in a 60 frames per second I
wish it just comes out in a 60 frames
and he's less they deal with it
and if in you gotta get in they're gonna
mix it up run it 500 be on that type of
game I honestly don't think the 60
frames or 30 frames is going to be that
much of a problem because then fps fast
which kind of a kind of video right it's
a slow pace let's let's let's work it
out type of game now if it was like a
Call of Duty oh yeah telling you right
they was telling you that you listen you
claim call of duty at 30 friends versus
the 60 know your differentiator then is
FPS versus the third person with the
person you're saying look and actually I
believe Brendan green said the same
comment you made where he said he
because he doesn't feel it was fast
twitch with the 60 frame that it
shouldn't be as much of a difference but
now you're saying I can see oh the
environment I mean good even
third-person also because if you talk
about like like gears like gears 30
versus 60 is the same thing cuz it's a
faster paced game it's just a nature the
nature of this game is about sneaking
around surviving popping a shot running
hiding no scam is this the same group of
people who was who's who's saying all
you know destiny to play so much better
feels so much better on PC but you know
when it comes to another scenario it's
like solutely we're definitely not
trying to minimize it now let me jump in
because this is fun no this was really
interesting because like I'm keeping it
and I'm like okay I see where the
community is toned for I see that the
majority is the S unis users they have
30 frames per second like this if that's
what it's gonna be maxed out let's just
say ideally it couldn't hit 60 I can
understand from a competitive standpoint
yes they would be at a disadvantage then
I'm thinking okay for the X guys that
point down the crash and you want the
best possible experience on your system
if your system can actually
we do it if it could be xbox what I
could do sixty then it is kind of filed
to say we're not gonna maximize the
potential of the hardware and it brought
me back as I was doing some research on
them a good friend shout out to Mike
Ibarra he listened to the show
may 19th she put out a tweet and this
was I believe around the whole destiny
to speculation remember at that time
nobody knew it was gonna run or whatever
so remember at the time everybody was
like yo that you know they're gonna hold
it back the Xbox one night that's when
people thought the Xbox one X could be
one destiny - right and they were like
yo could he hold back and he put out a
tweet he said developers are free to
choose how they use the power of the
Scorpio 50 he says we have no
requirements limiting framerate or
fidelity right so then a person on
Twitter responded to him so he was like
but what about FPS parity between Xbox
one and Scorpio he said which means a
2013 console is gonna hold a 2017
console back Mike Ibarra immediately
tweeted he said no there is it this is
up to the developer to choose for the
game to do right so based on what Mike
Ibarra was saying back then and I
remember I actually hit him in the DM
and I was like yo I was a powerful tweet
because a lot of people thought that
because of competitive parity they would
never make the Xbox one X version of a
FPS warframes percent but it's on record
yeah I have it here y'all May 19 go to
my favorites on May 19 6:41 p.m. I did
my research you know say check it out he
this is the platform that's like saying
that they will not hold back the
scorpion 1 frames per second so they
didn't care about the competitor would
be more funny to go back every time an
executive microsoft says something that
they went back on let's take a shuttle
but estimates now Mike Ibarra
Mike Shanin office I can't comment on
her she for a minute she's been saying a
lot of stuff she got in trouble with um
my McCaffrey
so I can't comment on her I can come
with my boy that I know I hear both
sides I hate Attica hey are you coming
from King I hate everybody here you come
from the short-term fix probably would
be what you guys are saying a shout out
today to chat is let yall charlton chat
like the short-term feel all in there
any going in it would be definitely the
lobby's now the argument for the lobby
against the lobbies would be why divide
the playerbase now I want to bring that
back to you so let's just say Xbox one X
comes out with a full version 60 frames
per second s 30 frames per second let's
just say they have a competitive 60
frames per second Lobby that gives the
Xbox one s guys the option to log in
we're almost like a warning disclaim
don't give me that okay you actually
just five minutes ago
I'm giving my opinion on something don't
mean I care about it but my question is
would you look having separate a lot of
these yeah like press fast vs. excuse if
they want to opt in they can do it if
not you don't feel like there would be
problems with the amount of people in
the pool nobody might be a couple
hundred people on the X and a couple of
thousand people on the s light at night
you might have enough to fill two
lobbies now here's the thing we would
assume again I'm assuming I could be
completely wrong
what about all solve he'll be honest is
is it a potential for Windows play
anywhere game buggy at this point I mean
they haven't talked about it yeah I'm
just if that were the case I never would
have said it already I remember them
saying that there's something that they
wanted to pursue that they want it yeah
yeah I don't know if that would be
something that they would pursue okay
don't seem natural they've got old
windows there's no windows store version
of it per se and if they were to pursue
that I don't think it's when the game is
at one point oh all I know is uh if they
may come if they pour it over the X
version and the S version onto the
Windows 10 that runs better on Steve
they might they might some steam use
like really bad on PC look at this I
want to bring it to the level for this
um all right with the statement from
branding great I want to get into the
logic I want to get into the culture why
this happened right now when he released
this statement what do you take Lord the
loud do you think it was one of those
things with the PR team said all don't
you say that 50 frames per second
happened internally what he's actually
did the original statement said all
right I got I got it all right so he
came out and he man was like bub GAA
smoke to his army and man said look they
asked him about you know the Xbox one X
version he said the team is pushing 160
he said definitely 60 frames per second
[Music]
we're not sure we may have to limit it
to 30 frames per second maybe but the
last time I saw it was running at
between 30 to 40 you said we're
constantly improving and tuning so he
said the aim was to get to 60 so one day
at this man he definitively said the
Xbox when I can do 60 frames per second
and then the next day um I misspoke I
previously he said then listen to his
statement though he goes I want to
clarify that pub he will run at 30
frames per second across all Xbox one
devices we're constantly refining the
game exploring options to increase
frames per second but this early in the
dev we're unable to confirm more so do
you think this is just PR speak that it
Xbox when X can do it and maybe they may
wait until like the final release
version let's go to the inners
I don't know
was going on in his head you know maybe
maybe he was just stating that they have
it at 16 he wasn't really referring to
the final release of the game he said
they got it yeah that looks bad damage
control if I've ever seen it he created
the game no yeah no so the thing about
it is and this is amazing should take
his Twitter from him it's it's all PR
because the thing about it is as
passionate as I am about getting the
maximum experience from my console it's
not what they promised they promised
parity across all consoles in relation
to this they said it when they said it
when they started talking about the
iterative concept so they promise so
it's like once again Microsoft they
jumped the gun a little bit mamas and
certain things that when things start to
play out they realized probably wasn't
the smartest thing to do here's the
things off the messaging is still bad
because if they're saying that you're
gonna get me able to play it across all
devices right we're getting uniformity
but then you got guys like Barros saying
that we are not holding the scorpio back
we're not holding the expec when it
comes to the mycube our thing he does
around the time the destiny 2 p.m. yes
that was a sweet it was 19 let's cut
that that uh that tweet for what it was
there's taken advantage of that whole
situation and trying to get put up on he
puts four series of tweets
and truth be told I'm gonna keep it one
on the arm I got someplace I'm inside
baseball I got I speak to Mike II borrow
some time and I hit him directly I was
like yo bro
tweet your zip and on he just hit me
back kind of like smiley face like they
easily confirming like yo they're not
gonna hold it back so again that's
inside baseball but I'm just saying at
the end of the day for him to say that
definitive oh it is
and he knew exactly what was gonna
happen like he didn't know that the
backlash would be is how it is right and
they told him listen we don't need any
negative press going into this game all
right so remember this is Microsoft's
little baby that they're holding in the
rocking it and then do anything with it
and they want this game to release into
this beta form and at the end of the
month they're gonna release it into the
wild after you know they work out the
kinks they just want to make sure it
works perfectly going through all right
they eat up the one any controversy you
know when the controversy is gonna kick
when that digital foundry comes out they
say they have the game running 240 on
the on the now you know are we talking
about a consistent 30 to 40 that's the
best time they can get consistent 32
fleming we have to try to push 60 on yes
we have des always say that they have
they have a 60 frame game and a dips to
30 40 frames all the time and again I'm
gonna ask you a question would you take
a 900p 60 frames per second puggy
what would you take a 900p 60 frames per
second player no would you would you
take it I mean as long as I could play
the game I I don't care like I was one
of the people that was had the
pitchforks talking about ten ATP's the
end-all be-all thing so you you heard it
here 900 peace 64 us's let's go you're
not gonna do that why not
here's the thing like okay sure they
might do that for like a compel that the
comparisons like you know I guess you
you know you guys have this this all
spin said that they only want to sell
X's if you can start comparing 700 PE to
whatever they have on the X let's go
make the s look significantly weaker and
then they're gonna drop down on itself
people like that is is weaker and don't
they what to show that doesn't matter
they still have that they still gotta
sell it
like right today they just drop them
that they want to sell more like why do
you think they haven't compared Xbox one
to Xbox at 1x games they had will have
one comparison on their Chado comparing
the both women compare where I'm
confused what's the foursome pairing s
games at X Games say I have one video
series add a box why would anyone look
worse than the other right because it's
a family of systems right baby
so both they're not trying to sell one
over there because that's a third party
platform that doesn't regardless for
their price right right I'm just
confused to your point I'm trying I'm
trying to get you're saying that if they
could only si think they can get at 910
with that let's say that I'd rather go
with I'm saying what Microsoft is
thinking you have the X version of 1440p
let's say the minimum it's 1440p then
you got the 900p version now you have
all these comparisons going people
thinking that the that the S is so
significantly weaker they start talking
in the pro because it's cheaper well
here's the thing don't you think
Microsoft wants to sell the X this is a
sprinter I said multiple times he knows
he's gonna sell more s as an accident
right but here's the thing is a new
system right and
saying that his mantra with this system
this is for the premium experience this
is the the hardcore gamer right okay so
if you're promoting this system almost
think of it as an elite controller right
the elite controller has significant
advantages over a standard controller
right it is you got the paddles you can
map things you can do all these things
so why would they not want to sell that
the premium device if it can do these
things that's the only thing I'm
confused about it's not that it's not
trying not to sell the eggs but they're
not going to do stuff to hurt the S to
sell the X that mess okay so yeah okay
the other thing is perception from from
damaging the the base yeah your thing is
like you don't want them you think that
they're gonna do everything in their
power because because they don't want to
hurt the S sales trying to promote the X
when the X is gonna so less than the s
and I'll tell you this if I tell you
this if they can get the S running at 60
frames per second whatever that
resolution is you run it at that
resolution you don't you don't say okay
I'd rather run it closer to 1080p but it
has to be 30 frames per second so it
doesn't look as bad next to the X no
wherever you can get that s running at
60 frames per second that's where you
put it if you can get it done and that
way there's not an issue with the X the
X is always going to be more powerful
it's always whatever most of what they
say in terms of are if if the
conversation if the conversation becomes
that the X becomes more popular because
of these things they would rather sell
you an X then an S or message they would
rather sell you an X because they want
to build that base this is their new
console and what to sell that console
we don't want to sell this they're not
abandoning liking it but here's the
reality that you don't see at the end of
the day let me let me finish let me
finish at the end of the day with any
type of new console it's only a matter
of time before they do start to slowly
phase out the said old console that's
just how gaming consoles work I mean as
long as I've seen it even if you have an
upgrade they can sit there and say yeah
we're gonna play nice with the ecosystem
and all the systems eventually we're
going to see situations like this and
it's happening so early right now right
where it's like the X version can do
this the S version can do that and
eventually I still agree shout to rich
review tech I eventually think maybe it
may not be a year from now maybe be two
years from now we are going to see X
only game I'm I'm convinced at some
point there's gonna be a period where
the S is not gonna be able to run it
certain things it's just facts just how
technology works and then what's gonna
happen there's gonna be a base that's
good it's the same thing with the Kinect
eventually they phased out the Kinect
you just say they're going to phase it
out at some point if the X continues on
an upward trajectory that's just my
opinion though I mean we're talking a
couple years down the line though
absolutely absolutely right here right
now it's gonna be interesting what
happens if they don't though there's
this whole situation like I keep
breathing they're still pushing to ds's
they got the nutrients it's been out for
a long time they're still trying to push
the two TS so it's that whole thing I'm
still trying to sell that base console I
just don't I don't know that it's a
definite that they're gonna be right I
mean this is the day a lot of you made
some great points the thing is we're in
this weird space where we have iterative
consoles that are kind of mimicking the
PC now your point with Nintendo is
interesting too because and this is kind
of defending Lord addicts point because
Nintendo's in a unique situation like
what there was a DSS stuff that thing is
so damn popular that base is so neat
you can't abandon that babe and that's
where Lord addicts argument is valid
that the Essbase is the strength of the
xbox right you know and and you can't
completely throw them away yet because
this is the majority but at the end of
the day I also feel like hey they're in
the business of selling consoles they
have a new one out they're gonna try to
sloly they're gonna play nice like if
they're not feel in the beginning the
first two years I feel like by the time
that happens I feel like Sony's gonna
drop their PS 5 and we're already gonna
be talking about new consoles I think by
the time that happens we're gonna be on
the next gen before possible they
started doing stuff like that it's
definitely bought I just thought this
was this is great because I don't think
there's a great chance that we won't see
another mijin console refresh though
like especially if you know the ex
doesn't break any records but you know
it's sold well but what's it gonna do
now mmm it's like the pro like you know
you never see you know people bragging
you never see Sony brag about Pro sells
so you know there's a good chance that
after the ps4 Pro and the Xbox one X we
won't see these again it's interesting I
think we'll see them again but they'll
be named differently I think this is the
last console in the Xbox one Xbox one
family mm-hmm please hit that like y'all
we're giving you a good game and talk
like continue so yes I just think I
think this is probably the last one we
see in the Xbox one family of because I
know more likely the next step for
PlayStation is 5 so you have to you have
to change up the name just just just a
perception sake you have change of the
name so yeah but uh look Mike I don't
really talk about resolution I don't
talk about any of this time I played
happy war rams you're passionate but
it's not friends it's just that's my
piggy you know what that's my opinion
and a lot of people agree with you I
don't get don't get it twisted like
Twitter was it was a civil war instead
like it was people were going at each
other's throat in
it's a part that kills me you got people
that part that don't even really dabble
in PC gaming and they'd be sitting there
saying frames don't matter and I'm like
why don't you play a couple more games
besides Marvel trouble obg they were
going at it and it was a couple of and
put the argument basically was you know
we shouldn't you know action be held
back and then you know the arcing West
versus like um you know headsets and
controllers I will play a sixty frame
the way the same game I got to sixty you
got third exactly attic I play mainly on
PC and sees a clear advantage that's
wrong people actually put time to PC
some rescuing I'm here to throw water on
a fire oh my god
really honestly when it comes to that
game you're my guy
you've been my guy since destiny won
you're my guy in destiny too um and it's
that's not gonna change cuz me and you
came well together
uh but these people out here just tiki
torches put your tiki torches down
brothers put them down it's it's not
dead it's not over everybody wants to
make this grandioso statement about this
game remember let the game flush
yourself out nod I am in that majority
that says that they should have kept all
the baseline stuff that they worked so
hard for just anyone and let it carry
over and build from there and don't have
us pay for stuff that we already did and
sequential DLC that's gonna come later
because you know for a fact when these
other DLCs come out these
microtransactions and these are upgrade
the guns because you know Chris likes to
do get the master role on the guns he
chase his dad and strike specific loot
and loot for the raid that actually
works for the raid stuff that we had in
place they took away that's where the
anger comes from you know if you used to
get in a cocktail fruit with your dinner
and your mother takes it away like
listen we already established cocktails
you are you understand so this is this
just for the people that don't play
destiny I'm just giving you analogy for
what's going on now
they're gonna give us that cocktail
fruit later but they're gonna give it to
us and of course like now you gotta pay
50 cents for this cocktail through and
you like now I was getting it for free
that's what we don't want it to be and
that's where it is because they already
set it up that way and he prefaced it in
the beginning with K saying that
everything got blown up we starting from
scratch no that's not the narrative okay
you know yeah that stuff starts from
scratch the guns and stuff and the way
that you go to different areas that
starts from scratch but what you
establish what we grind for what we put
400 500 hours in for we should not have
to fight for that and get that back in
DLC so everybody's saying that the game
is dead and I want to know no please no
no Jamie I wanna know what can they do
because Tuesday is a big day for me and
I'm pretty supposed a big day for a lot
of people now for that yeah it's it's
it's hopefully they get a couple of
things right and I gotta get everything
right right but it's gonna bring a lot
of us back and they're talking about
catering to us hardcore but what did
they mean what haven't they mentioned to
you to get you back and what are you
missing that you want to play this is a
good question um I got a bunch to talk
about this let me get our guests let's
get a little apple um first of all I'm
assuming that you're not a destiny
player or I did I played so let me get
your perspective from the outside
looking in with this whole situation
obviously there's a big unrest in the
community Bungie came out with a big
article this week in reference to that
everything with Lord King is saying
about trying to improve it for you know
the curse works out as DLC that drops on
Tuesday so where's your whole thought
process of what you've been seeing of
what was going on so are we are we going
to discuss the
progression issue - or design mm-hmm so
just as a blanket thing me looking at
destiny - like with any RPG I like to
put in as much time as I feel I got my
$60 worth because frankly for me RPGs is
a lot of times especially like this
there's no real end in sight so you just
keep going and going going the
fundamental problem that I have with
destiny is that it clearly wants to be
an MMO it's doing like the marketing is
all like MMO MMO but at the end of the
day they're not doing things that MMOs
do the the walling your content first
and foremost walling any Content behind
a paywall
it just it for me who has played other
MMOs who that I think operate better it
just it doesn't it doesn't speak very
well to me so walling content and
expansions behind paywalls
is something that a lot of mmo's don't
do so you're already messing up there if
you want to build that base you want to
keep that base you got to keep giving
them something new to do I'm one of
those people who hit that level cap
really fast I Drive through it and I was
just like wow this is a great game but
personally I'm not the kind of person to
just keep going and doing raids and
things like that so they didn't really
have anything for me to do catch and I
already deleted it off of my PlayStation
so I'm not gonna reinstall it it's just
things like that there's a lot of
barriers to you know continued play for
people like me who don't feel as though
I'm getting a value out of things like
the expansions there's no way for me to
taste their test drive you know
expansions and things like that either
because once again it's completely
walled off by expansion passes and then
you've got the experience nonsense that
was that was like that was the nail in
the coffin for me with destiny yeah I
needed it you are doing these insidious
things too and a lot of people are you
know they're trying to brush off the
idea that they were doing it to try and
sell bright engrams about that XP
throttle II so much sense to me if I was
a business person so much the idea that
they were upfront about things like that
that what am i what am I supposed to
think as a consumer about your game
about your company
your development company or anything
like that if you guys are doing
nefarious things like that that doesn't
make any sense to me
[Laughter]
this is someone who doesn't play at
hardcore this is someone who plays other
mi yeah and it's just me looking at it
like I've said I put so many hours into
other MMOs and I've seen companies do
what they're trying to do and I've seen
other companies you know learn from that
and this is just something they're gonna
have to learn maybe in destiny 3 you
know yeah that's that's something that
happens but genuinely in an MMO setting
it's about keeping and maintaining your
base they're gonna be people who come
and go all the time but you hacked your
base some thank you I'm so glad you said
that which is gonna help
Komatsu you not noticed um we are we are
destiny conversation with the last table
because we don't have time for that so
if you want to talk about esta nee then
you know by all means talk about destiny
if you are talking about
frames-per-second talking to yourself
Luka is what important and the thing is
I'm specifically like war potentially
perfect to sing because that's my exact
opinion in regards to destiny they need
to find the balance to keeping the
balance will come in and but then also
doing meant to met at MMO sensibilities
so that the hardcore have something to
do but I don't think has it's Bungie
ever came out openly and said that they
modelled this game like an MMO of course
they're not gonna say but but then I
don't understand why you guys expect
this to be honest as this riddle in and
of itself is the mode then why do you
guys expect it to be
not milk they have been over the years
every kata acted like it's not like
there's something else you told me in
the beginning was you're an MMO and I've
been running with that in the same vein
of a World of Warcraft which is not um
you know World of Warcraft you have 100
people raids and that's really it gets
really fun um I thought it kind of
sucked that you only had six people in
the race and the public events also
originated in exactly any any game were
in which the community is the central
focus about it it kind of lends itself
to that MMO feel like that's that's what
they're trying to do try to make it make
and build that community around it so
the people are alright what about what
about games like overwatch that's a
community game right but it's not it's
not a living world it's not this games
as a service that the phrase they keep
trying to push and shove down our
throats oh is in and of itself it's
something that people come back to and
they they build themselves within this
game that's like it's more than just
having um you need a place it's a
community that's invested does things
together like the raids and things like
that the the content behind it it's way
different modelled towards community as
opposed to overwatch you you go in blind
matches and things like that it's at the
end of the day man like to be completely
in a hut percent honest with you guys
I'm over destiny like I they I watch
these streams and I didn't even know
they canceled the third stream that you
know you know and this is coming from
someone that has over a thousand hours
in the first one got like 500 hours in
this one it's just let's be grew here
man the game's not dead but we are not
the thing that they're looking for now I
want to jump in and
think Lorax you making some good points
I mean Chad tubewrapper the checks and
you think they trying to be everything
to everyone it's one of those things
right now that I consider this a
watershed moment for destiny this is
where this thing can go left very
quickly and obviously the community the
community is very upset the playerbase
you know obviously since the XP
throttling which talked about last
episode you know they got exposed for
lying which basically like lab said it's
pretty much promoting their little micro
transaction system you know I hear what
Lloyd Carr box was coming from as far as
they have to do something for the
hardcore base I mean what how about so
we've gone at this nauseam with each
other like you know we will send message
to each other's daily just talking about
what destiny needs to do and trust me I
hear what you guys are saying let in or
and even you're looking in the sense
that we all know this thing is following
a WoW MMO conover framework right in its
core basis and Emily whatever they can
say to try to avoid it it is you know
I'm saying now the end of the day is the
problem right now is they haven't been
doing enough for the hardcore base cuz
you got guys like like you said well
glob well he powered through she's got
everything he's gotta get and he's gone
and the problem is the destiny one had
so many of these hardcore
activities and things that rewarded you
that kind of showed your level of
dedication in the game and because they
got rid of a lot of those systems and
these things they work so hard from year
one destiny to year three destiny that
wasn't available at launch we got or
living
you know I knew something was wrong
not necessarily it was bad mm-hmm when I
grinded like crazy to get prepared for
the rate for the Leviathan raid and when
they dropped the numbers I'm like
fifteen sixteen light levels higher than
the actual like highest maximum light
well so like right there it was kind of
like a little red flag was like you know
it was like if this would have been
destiny one love I panned when it came
out 390 right what a red flag for me and
like I said she'll talk about who is
that
when they put the clam thing out I might
okay clams that's a but to me would
disgusted me is when green law again and
in people who did not even do the Ray
didn't even do trials are going to
Hawthorne and collecting engrams and
getting trials weapons trials gear a
raid weapons raid gear without stepping
foot in those activities that to me was
a red flag that to me is now you're
catering too much at a casual base and a
minute day these are the things that
kept the hardcore going and these random
roles and these things that grind for in
in ornaments like they had all these
great systems at the end of the
lifecycle of nesting one that was not
there so that to me is when I was like
whoa this is a problem because
everyone's getting the 300 or whatever
it is very fast they've done everything
they had to do there's nothing else more
to ground for and even shout that acaba
so like great quest like the black
spindle number stuff like that stuff
like the sleeper simulant quest way it
was it really took so much to put these
things together these exclusive weapons
so right now to really back in to what
Lord King is saying you know can they
turn it around the obviously they put
the blog post out and I gotta be honest
like I wasn't expecting much from this
you know about all the changes they're
gonna do for cursor Osiris all the
changes coming in in late December all
the changes coming in January and I will
say what the masterworks thing with the
random rolls they're doing they lately
pretty much stated they're gonna have
all these new systems rewards to keep
people engaged also better rewards from
the hardcore players private matches and
crews basically all the things that
we've been complaining and do you think
the reason why do you think Hawthorne is
the reason why the ray guns don't have
specific perks for the Ray yeah it's two
part I think the mistake they made is
they they went for the money the casual
base makes money at the end of the day
you get new people to come to your game
that's never played your game the
problem with is the casual base that
once they get said they made it so easy
for progression to get to that target
that once they got there the casuals
like okay we got everything
oh by the way assassin's creed's out
later by the way you know Mario's out
peace mm-hmm the casual they're done
with you so who's left the we're the
guys that promote exactly to the to the
casual to say hey come on you know all
these people come on and play on okay
car box I know you wanna come but I can
hear you I mean as in couples right
you're wrong my whole thing with it is
the casuals are fine when they get to
that middle ground they're fine with
going through the dailies going through
the night falls and their gang their
special exotic it's fine they're done
but when it comes to the hardcore guys
who can do the braids do the rape
procedures and get that super gear or
especially also the the trials right
here that you get from the trials they
don't care about that they were like
good right I can't do that see that's
the thing because trials shout the more
sinister shout out to be money in the
chat I feel what you saying on PvP bro
Krause was a badge of honor
only the elite could do that right if
you're giving away the gear and the
weapons that are further you lead in a
basic clan Ingram with all you got to do
is login because you're down with a crew
that's problem that is a problem you
don't say like they've casualized so
many hardcore in-game activities because
it's this feeling like we have to get
everyone involved and I get it from one
standpoint but you can't give away the
gig you got to provide content like
shots of us Lord Tomo in the chat he's
made a great point you got to provide
content for the castles but you still
gotta cater to the hardcore and that's
what Bungie messed up their definition
is the thing is they fail to remember
that the casual base only matters at
launch
yes it only matters that they're gonna
walk away from the game again you're
trying to get more people to become hard
right right trying to get them in and
not close them off no I wouldn't let saw
me little salami
so so they made that mistake where they
they didn't create the middle ground my
thing like moving forward what they have
to do is they have to create another
tier I think they did the casual stuff
is so ingrained in the game as it is now
that rolling it back would be a huge
mistake
and I think what they need to do is just
they need to focus on creating another
tier mm-hmm where the hard core can live
can stay and play their endgame content
because at this point I think just the
other stuff is too integral to the game
that you would break it you would
completely break it if you tried to just
run it all back so this is the mistake
they made with it with this game I
understand wanting to get more people in
I understand wanting to give people the
Maricopa laughter people walked away
from destiny one but hey you know they
messed up in another way right the first
one was was the first one was content
light and and little by little they
improved upon that and in with this one
it was just like they tried to be
everything to everyone right and you
just can't because the people that
matter at the end the day gonna stick
with it I'm running away from it in
droves now and that that's the key right
now look at let me explain something
y'all shout out the Lord anchorman you
know shower egg we used to be in a
battle with Laura a good man during the
destiny one favor right I've refused to
admit he was right about anything he's
still wrong but we got to say this right
Lord de la boum um basically dashboard
there's this category called most plate
right the game that's the most played on
xbox live and they show you about the
top 20
during this console lifespans on you
know destiny won the game like man
destiny won even in its lowest ERA like
pre taking king or whatever would always
sit from either the number one spot may
be known or than the number five spot
and even in Begay like I said even with
the games at its lowest point the player
base was still there mmm-hmm fast
forward now to 2017 after that first
Daphne - absolutely took the number one
spot as soon as he came out in September
playerbase was engaged after about a
month it's not even in the top ten
anymore it's right fortnight it's it's
Co D and in destiny would be able to
withstand those games like it would be
even withstand it like even if it would
drop it would never fall out of
existence out of a top ten that means
the player base is gone they are out so
the cat not only the casuals left right
the hardcore they've pissed off the
hardcore to the point where the hawk was
like look I'm seeing popular destiny
south of more cactus he's going to show
you know I'm saying Holtzman these guys
are talking about hey guys what are we
doing on fortnight tonight dropping next
week I mean the week after that's a
problem yeah I do want to say that it's
like they had the right mentality during
destiny one you know they kind of had
that you know Don Mattrick mentality you
know complain about all this is too hard
well we got something for you you know
if you don't like rays because it's too
hard we got something for you
it's called strikes with no strikes
Pacific loot for you know I'll talk
about destiny one oh yeah absolutely
it's like we got something for you it's
called the crucible trials to hard play
The Crucible it's like that's what
they're messing up this it's they took
the stuff that kept the hardcore happy
life like during the last game and they
catalyze the [ __ ] out of that - let me
ask a question though as someone who has
a I haven't played it in a little bit
for the hardcore gamers is it still
possible to stay hardcore without
purchasing the expansions why do you
think did something they can no no
always been about that DLC continuing
okay model themselves after the World of
Warcraft model which is yep the right
level gets raised the level get you know
and you have to complete that end game
to reach max cap and the funny the funny
thing is it's not like one of those
things where you know maybe they give
you a couple of weeks no it's usually
the first week is
is a new exclusive rate that comes to
the new expansion yeah you gotta climb
real hard and you know the neck the rate
comes out the following weekend
everybody is tuning in but what I was
seeing and what I'm noticing is if
they're yelling out with these tiki
torches and they're telling you that
it's burning to the floor that doesn't
really make you want to go back I'm
confident a lot of people that were
playing purchased the season pass and
they will show up on chance to see but I
want to know do you think that the fifth
is gonna impress enough to keep them
that when the other patches come out
they say you know I'm gonna go back and
try it at out right because if it's not
compelling enough in this December 5th
patch right there won't be good yeah I
think the story content has to be
compelling to bring back a lot of the
the casuals yes and then and then have
them kind of stumble upon all the
hardcore stuff that they're hopefully
adding to this stuff and then stick
around but I think the stories stuff has
to be prime right absolutely absolutely
that's the first part of it in the
second part of it is like again deep I
saw the blog post they made their me a
coke they apologized and they're saying
all the right things they on the right
path to doing the right things what we
want the question is you know like Lola
King said will it be enough and I think
it's gonna come down to the hard core is
having to give the cosign that hey these
are baby steps this is the right
direction I mean I honestly don't see it
completely turning around until like
spring or possibly the next you know
taking King style DLC they gotta take
away attics unrelenting hate for
apartment 2c last week oh I got us
classic I wanted to throw one thing on
that especially in this good that what
King here so you can I back up
we access a NMOS not like you you think
I was saying great teeth and the
apartments by the way said before that
was a feature more the Warcraft actually
implemented that first but they
implemented that after they have about
six or seven grades it was something to
add a little bit of variety I feel their
issue that they have with that is like
if you only have one raid you should not
be putting that that's after you have
like seven or eight raised up to the
belt so you can change stuff up and keep
people playing with them alright that's
that was like a initial look about you I
honestly think and this is my opinion um
remember this thing is big enough to eat
planets right so when you were doing a
raid you were going down to Mars are you
going to Venus you were going to planets
they can correct this by going to
planets inside of Leviathan
joint daddy's a lot yeah I think it is
gonna be vex you know I think it's gonna
be back steam but at the end of the day
it's like regardless if you know it's
perception it's like it could be a
completely different scenario a
completely different look and it's still
at the Leviathans
being and its effects boss I got a sea I
got I'm willing to give it a chance
my big issue is like I want them to act
like it's a raid and not like a rate
activity like yeah take away that word
that status that you're hating because I
you know what to be honest with you in
this year two majority you right had
right now all the tiki torch guys
because he's a hardcore guy and he's
upset that's a problem well let's wrap
that let's go
we got like that was that good good
tablets boys and to move old Lord some
yellow spotlight going on with the blade
corner himself talk to us alright guys
so they'll play chronicles to the last
big release for Nintendo for the year
and it is a hardcore hardcore old-school
style JRPG if you like old-school
Suikoden old-school Final Fantasy this
is the game for you you love all right
day you love grinding you love weird
characters weird arcs this is the game
for you
um so Xenoblade Chronicles 2 is the
sequel to Xenoblade Chronicles which
really came out on the Wii and then the
unemployed Chronicles X that came to the
Wii U in 2015 I think so this game uh
let me take it from a technical aspect
first the game is beautiful
the game has this sort of painterly sort
of anime look kind of mixed with like
steampunk and a sensibilities so it's a
beautiful game the game runs I saw a few
hitches in handheld mode and then when I
doctored it actually ran a little
smoother the game yeah so that's it like
the game the game runs pretty well the
34 interesting game but again art style
sort of supersedes any sort of technical
little misgivings that you might see I'm
on Freeman but I'm scared too so why are
you afraid to you're gonna define glass
looking for a do ya they gonna get you
they gonna get you especially story wise
so now when it comes to the story the
story is pretty cool it really it's kind
of cliched in some ways just like a lot
of JRPGs the the protagonist is a guy
who basically like you know searches for
records and stuff and treasures
and he very you know all weirdos are the
weirdest so his deal is that uh he takes
on a mission for an exceptional amount
of money he doesn't know who his
employer is what I want him to get he
literally didn't do any kind of research
you just took this kind of spoiling but
it's the first five minutes of the game
guys it's very early on in the game so
the thing is and this is an arc that
they have for a lot of protagonist and
JRPGs it they have this not naivete to
them usually very good and then they put
themselves in a situation where they
have to save the world but in the
process to think about JRPGs that are
very interesting is that in the process
of the story you kind of find the dirty
underpinnings of these people because
they're forced to be put in situations
where they have the murder they have
their it's just you know oh yeah they
murder a lot so so it's a it's a very
interesting story arc in terms of in
terms of voice acting I think the main
character Rex is voiced very well uh
Conor McGregor like it's not like Zelda
you get like five cutscenes the whole
game no son they got a cutscene
they got King they got cutscenes like
every five minutes
yeah there's long expressions like
they'd be good it's like you're watching
this de Saturday morning JRPG cartoon
that's going down like they want to talk
about and everything you want to Brad I
mean when you're walking around the
world and talking to NPCs you it's just
gonna be text but anything story-wise
and yeah you're gonna it's gonna be
fully voiced some of the english voices
you know it couldn't be a little hit or
miss but the main protagonist pack
though you can download they do and it's
something about there's something for me
personally
the Japanese voice back I can't play the
entire game like that this is 100 our
investment I want to hear English flags
and use the banter between the
characters in I'm pretty decent like I
think I'm probably six seven hours and
do now like one of the biggest things
that I'm kind of noticing that like I
enjoyed the the the dubbed at the
beginning you know like they were really
good but then I'm sitting here like is
everyone from everywhere British I'm
serious like I feel like everyone I'll
talk to and like it'd be different if it
was like one section like this is
nothing like everywhere I go someone's
iron it's like the same two accents and
I'm like I'm like yo I just said you'd
be like now here no black people no
white they have a little bit but it
makes for some entertaining conversation
like like like like kognito said like
the the banter means a lot so having the
japanese voice packs for me like I just
can't not not for a game has dis
involved right kind of like they were
having a self like the the varnish in
Hyrule enact the game is humongous when
I say humongous I am NOT being this is
not hyperbole the game is huge for
anybody who thinks that dropping a
Xenoblade game with two years after the
last one means that they shortchanged
this one no the world I'm one huge
the world is amazing you're basically
you're human mankind is living on the
backs of these animals called Titans now
these beasts right and basically those
are the worlds that you explore so it's
these living like ecosystems that you're
exploring and you're fighting in um it's
it's a it's a design element that's
beautiful to see and because the way
each animals like body sort of
contours to make different things that
you would see like in nature is is a
very cool thing to see and I to me it
sets the game apart from a lot of other
games in terms of design in that regard
um in terms of gameplay it's there's one
thing about JRPGs that I I kind of
always never liked but I still continue
to play is the fact that I don't like
auto attacking is weird about that yeah
yeah I like pressing buttons to attack
that's why I sort of gravitate more to
it
so western style RPGs but that said um
there's a lot of depth in this fighting
system so basically the fighting system
is kind of a like a two-person thing you
are what they call a driver right and
you have you have a person that's
attached to you tethered to you
literally called a blade right and the
blade is what provides the power to you
to attack your project it provides the
magic enterprise your attack power and
your job is to basically sort of use
strategy in terms of how you fight turn
and turn on certain enemies and
placement before the fight stuff like
that so it's something that I haven't
really seen in the RPG before and it's
implemented very well it's very cool um
and to me it speaks to like larger sort
of themes in the actual story because
you know this person that's whose fate
is tethered to you you know there's a
lot of things about like slavery and
subservience II and stuff like that
um and for what I've seen so far this
JRPG handles all that stuff very well
like I think it has in the end it's
gonna have something kind of powerful to
say um what I played so far of it I'm
only like again six seven hours and what
I play so far of it I'm loving it but it
is an acquired taste in that if you're
not a JRPG head and you know what you're
getting into
you might feel overwhelmed because it's
very systems heavy um a lot of menus to
sort of go through a lot of nuances to
the fighting that you have to kind of be
prepared to learn and if you're willing
to do that and you're willing to explore
this is as good a JRPG as you're gonna
see like it really is it surprised me
that too
years out from the last one they're able
to make something with this much depth
this little things that obviously they
could they could have maybe taken more
time with like I said like those like
the voice I think and stuff and I got a
question me and like a lot of JRPGs came
out this year a lot of RPGs this year
and let's assume that I have all the
systems right you know would you highly
recommend the game opposed to like other
ones like you know as far as Final
Fantasy even though Final Fantasy this
time has been a little Western as very
westernized right um so you know you
have a couple of other RPGs that came
out this year and would you recommend
that above them because I'm looking to
get the game I didn't know because I
have so many games this year which is
crazy
um but if it's if it's a must-own I want
to know if it's on switch I think it is
definitely a must-own on switch I think
if somebody somebody who's looking for a
hardcore JRPG Imam and and didn't get
that with Final Fantasy and like you
said has been westernized especially in
terms of the combat stuff like that's
been westernized um and if the persona 5
sort of aesthetic doesn't appeal to you
there's I know for JRPGs like I'm the
type of guy like high fantasy stuff the
high fantasy the steampunk stuff when
you take it into modern day for me I
lose interest a little bit I eat
personas fantastic but if if you want
your JRPGs to have that sort of like
fantastical you know be stuff and like
craziness yeah then this is definitely
gonna be more up your alley
like I said in terms of like pure
old-school turn-based grindy JRPG stuff
this is this is like that's what I miss
I hate the free roam and
crap I hate it I swear I love you know
the the turn base okay you know this guy
is gonna make that move you have to
strategize and look the funny thing with
this the funny thing with this is that
it's kind it kind of walks that line a
little bit blurs it because let's say
you get into a fight right with it with
an enemy it's you can you get into the
fight into the in the open world it's
not like you can see the enemy you walk
towards them and you fight now you could
be in the middle of that beef and
somebody walking around like near you
could stumble upon the beef and oh I'm
fighting two more guys now like it kind
of walks that line a little bit where
you once you get into a fight doesn't
isolate you to that fight like happen
and plus I was running through this
little pond and then I started hearing
the music play and I'm sitting here
looking around I'm like where is that
music coming from and I looked up and
like a level 76 bird was chasing me I
was like yeah good luck right now to run
away actually is based on my facing did
you get a chance to pick up our
Xenoblade or waiting so yeah like I said
I'm one of those people who can't finish
a game for anything so I need to see
what's gonna happen in January with the
direct first that way I know exactly how
much time I have before the next big
release then then I can drop it because
I really I just don't think I have the
time to invest in that game like it
deserves you gotta wait a month to
realize that you can one other month to
play is dead look look the window okay I
don't know if you notice like with video
game awards by the way go vote they've
got this thing called the most
anticipated games and I thought it was
really funny how like I think four of
the five games aren't like that or
PlayStation exclusives announced their
games way earlier the Nintendo does ok
Nintendo though they don't they don't
really tell you the next game that's
coming out you know eight months from
now you know that kind of thing a lot of
times so I need to know where my money
is going
only lately yes II realize that like
nothing significant is gonna come out in
the first three months but here's the
dig no they right now that um II a shout
out the lost Boeing media they're having
a Nintendo Direct as well and J anywhere
Hey so I remember before they wore some
we would wait and see you know what
happens with switch it's popping with
boxes and there's a rumor at home can
you know what I'm talking about calm it
was III EA showed a game it was like a
prison I don't know how true it is what
is your claiming that it might be
delayed to 2019 I heard some of this
multiple platforms these things oh yeah
I heard switch to be Street so we'll see
yeah
so you might be Street stood over the
PlayStation I think that's more key
because I remember there was a there's
interview with the developer guy talking
about how much trouble he was having
[Laughter]
quick question home I know you kind of
held off because you have our ESO for
the switch based on what you've seen so
far as you know but is something that
you might pick up later on down the road
or you're still gonna be on side Skyrim
probably got you soul right now DLC to
it's coming this month out one more
point about 2017 you want to get him
fully wrapped yes yeah final thing on
gentle blade get that game if you love
JRPGs if you love RPGs give it a try it
is a fantastic game you just got to
stick with it because it's hardcore now
that said with Xenoblade being like the
last big release for a nintendo of the
year with club G being the last big
release for for Xbox for the year and
Sony basically kind of done for the year
in terms of stuff emailing it in with it
their parties and satisfied continued we
think at this point I think we can we
can have a pretty decent opinion on this
who do we think one 2017 and why you
know III think sir stuff is pretty
obvious I know Lord Coty's game I'm
gonna say Nintendo for because they had
all the games that they released was the
triple-a titles I couldn't do without
yeah I needed them in my life I needed
that Zelda like I needed drugs I don't
do drugs I don't see their mismanagement
of DLC sucks to me the content is not
compelling I'm so sorry you have to have
compelling content for me to purchase
not getting me Bo cereal boxes I went
out and purchased every last of me Bo
for Zelda for this upcoming DLC that's
supposed to work for it and you know
same thing with Mario
you saw a posting those guys I'm gonna
support these guys I'm gonna support
them if you're gonna work in my lane I'm
gonna be in that languaging we don't do
together alright
my thing is I want story driven deals
content give me that no give me little
wounds apartment to see no that's
exactly what they did it was like hey
check it out you can to see over here
and it's a little bit harder than it
wasn't to wait no no no I don't want
that I'm so please step that up you know
and that's about it but Nintendo won a
year I'm sorry it's a fact yeah one of
the X I got the eggs and they made every
other game beautiful Sony came in second
the Microsoft came in third lord addict
well you had with 2017 system one to you
I guess your I said any you know why you
won't we think I thought you was on the
fence with it because mean you had this
talk offline and for the masses right
the switch year has been a fantastic
year but for you I know you like you
have to better games at the whole year
the dates it's about the games and they
had the truth but my question I guess my
question for you is this before
Xenoblade Chronicles you kind of fell
off with Nintendo he was like after
Zelda I'm good you wasn't really feeling
you you really wasn't a splatoon guy you
wasn't an arms guy by all their big
stuff cart but you really wasn't my even
the Indies that I was loving it means
solver going crazy about you wasn't
really crazy
it's not until Zeno and I hit them like
yo yo check out that Z no you look okay
I'm gonna jump in on it and you jumped
in on his II know and you love in it so
my question is before Z no to was this
still have been your pick for who won
2017 yeah Wow because Sony and Nintendo
you know not so much on Sony a little
bit better on Sony but Microsoft just
completely dropped the ball this year
and for the most part you know Sony had
good games but none of them like you had
to add their games up to compete with
right so let me ask
well even with the the neo the horizon
zero dawn the light the hell just came
out I had more fun with Zoda than
anything I play it on PlayStation okay
facts Lord de la PO where you who you
have winning 2017 so it was actually
really close for first and the reason
why I say that is because with me it
usually comes down to discussion what
are people talking about more what was
made the most impact I would go Nintendo
Microsoft and Sony and the reason why
yes no Nintendo they came out of the
gate they did something nobody it was
expecting everybody was talking they
were talking nonsense they were like
this isn't gonna sell they look at that
that wait so they they came out of the
gate they came out strong they came to
helping out fantastic content and what
he was saying addict was saying was very
true when you talk about you know
horizon somebody's gonna bring up Zelda
when you talk about near all these games
it's gonna bring him Selda you know
we're lucky sale
Mario horizon people almost anyone that
played both you say but I enjoyed Zelda
more yeah and the reason why I say
Microsoft came out in second as opposed
to Sony's because Sony for a long time
has genuinely just been coasting they've
just they've been they were this place
with their they're playing it safe
they're complacent they're going half a
year without releasing the first party
game you know the people are really
talking about that to me does not scream
that I'm you know for the players or
whatever that forget about that
everything came out to begin the year
was a third party dead that was just
closer yeah when did he'll play come out
I'm just curious afore that oblate third
party well when did it go just out of
curiosity mom continued yeah and they
just have this whole thing we're
Microsoft at least you know when you
look objectively even if someone who
doesn't own an Xbox I'm what I am
eventually you know that is it speaks to
me because they do a lot of things that
say hey we are here for the consumer you
know they do
quality of life stuff that I really like
to see and I would love it if Sony did
that you know it just really simple
things I think that Microsoft is making
a lot of moves positively and I can't
wait to see what they do in 2018 and
that's why my mother shut out the Ginji
gadget to try he said Nintendo's game
come out every six months like one every
six months like like Sony drop like two
this year like are you gonna hold them
to the fire like you can't count persone
all them dude that said that's
third-party exclusives like so we got
gonna compare on Verizon and uh in
sports and you know and I feel it I feel
getting going on listen from what but
every six months the game came out every
month whatever money I don't know what
[Applause]
is it like for me is definitely Nintendo
hands-down because every month there was
a major release at least every month
every other month but the thing I don't
think Nintendo gets enough credit was
that were you a third party and the
games in between that people are
forgetting like your NBA 2k 18 came on a
switch off you know say like that's a
big deal like I see that the Sony guys
tend to ending mark so guys tend to be
like oh yeah cuz we get that every year
right but a games yes so you guys clean
ESO no good
[Laughter]
[Music]
walking down with the portability just
I'm at work y'all plain Xenoblade
Chronicles you like it just is so much
it sold it to me that's my personal game
here you know at the end of it you know
I still give someone a second
I know people saying there's a lot of
gaffer stuff they still had a great line
of great exclusives you know the we
bless people running off I kicked off
the year of the L in 2017 I can't give
you Xbox just because like the only good
game that really came out this year for
their platform was like lucky tail a lot
of people don't even say that
listen trust me it's really that
Nintendo people want to fight that you
can't fight it you just gotta you know
submit you lay down bend that knee
because if you played Zelda and I'm
telling you if you did play Zelda you
will understand why it's probably my
game of the year Salvage year with the
ex you know I'm saying you know they
really came about on strong ZN and just
happy to see them you know feeling good
about the system again and now you get
to see in 2018 good feeling back you
know why the ex is so important and I
feel that Microsoft you know have a
solid three is a solid three that was
pushing Sonya but Sony had two games my
bad I did forget about Halo Wars - no
disrespect halo was 2 n cuphead with
grapes now so real quick we got our own
new ILP poll this week we do let's go
for the room one more time and if you
want to change your uh your your been
the knee segment thing I'm not changing
out just you guys we looking for knees
shoutout to ankle is premature killing
of me and attic
Friday don't matter Pro egg a bit early
could have been like 10 between all of
them but you know they walk because they
saw ten more let them fight fight I'm
not saying anything they got too much
recorded evidence in the wake of the
pubsey framerate controversy if the Xbox
one X is capable of pushing 60 frames
per second in a competitive multiplayer
game when the Xbox one s is unable sure
you wanna form frame rate be used at 30
frames per second Hey yes competitive
parity must be kept be no X is a premium
product and was not be held back or C I
don't care I'm trans Dino blade I want
the four to be DS wrong Lord Kingdom
this [ __ ] please Rock the Vote hit
the IOP Twitter poll shout-out to Lord
the level of potentially perfect for
coming through people find you that Oh
everywhere I mean even tumblr we're
still using that
you might need to rephrase that [ __ ] you
post that Twitter at poper we're on
YouTube we do some twitch streaming
every once in a while but you know
mainly our streamings here our content
is mainly you know editorial type pieces
and highlight gaming just all humor
based but ice yeah anything anything
that oh we got cooking up that we should
be on the lookout for promote brother so
I'm actually going to be doing an
editorial really soon should be up by
the end of this week about giving
developers the the credit both positive
and negative that they deserve
especially when it comes to things like
publishers and how we like to send to
give them a lot of flack when I do
believe that in artistic integrity is
very important mom so when you're
allowing things like that in to get your
game you deserve just as much blame as
we give companies like EA so that's just
things like that and of course I need
one more Hammad bro segment what's this
it's a golf game for ps4 drinking game
we lost each other how many is in Europe
the Pope earth crew totally it's you
Steve it one more or yeah there's Louis
he's dreaming yeah
God shout out to Lewis and all that you
gotta definitely get you production
value they do really good stuff man like
I said we support everybody big small it
doesn't matter if you putting out good
content potentially perfect and our
hearts they will always be some twisted
stuff cuz on related channels is still a
get good gave the other get good gaming
I got a funny video on what happened
about the knee make sure you guys check
that out that's got hilarious dude so
look I box ooh with the new challenger
has appeared so we can find people find
you know they can find me on xbox on
Laura Basu same thing for the Twitter
plus also on the rare times I acts
do go to Disneyland which I call Sony
only thing I do with Sony is I play
their games and go back to the other
systems you had a controller a bit no I
just want to I do want to say one thing
real quick
notice this man didn't say steam what
happened in the steam oh here we go
how many years jenji gadget says sony
games are too hard for y'all you gotta
come back make sure you in this channel
is solely reppin you want like next week
- next week gonna be good
know that so uh Lord addict awaken sign
find you I'm probably gonna stream some
blood-borne today I don't know you can
find me on youtube gaming addict you can
find me on xbox room to kill you can
find me on PlayStation room to kill you
can find me on Steam which numbers are
so you'll have to just try to find me
there was an interesting conversation
thanks for the viewers we had a pretty
full day so uh you guys have a good
absolutely Lois solve the technical or
back in the biz we can find we'll find
you you can find me on PSN and xbox live
at being sovereign and lost North stop
IOP on twitter and definitely a big
shout outs Lord Allah before coming
through um
Lord de la PO reached out to me months
ago and we had a great conversation on
his channel about where the gamers know
what they want or not and Mortensen
unfortunately some technical issues that
we were not aware of - the end of the
and he got lost to the ether but it was
a fantastic conversation and it's great
to finally get him on the podcast we
yeah we've all felt to eat there
sometimes it's happened that's the gate
the Lord King with that preview [ __ ]
gtalk do they have your thank you for
coming through every guess is well
appreciated because I know you take the
time I specially we're early right now
so man you was here nice and early and
you had great energy I love it umm very
insightful on everything and I
definitely have to tech check out a
potentially perfect I really do um
everybody get you can catch me on
Twitter Instagram Facebook
PlayStation PSN forget Qi you'll get at
me on PlayStation is Xbox 360 lover oh
one I'm right there in another note and
don't get political at all right um but
it's an awareness that I want everybody
to be aware of is petitions out here go
and if you care at all there's a crisis
in Libya sign up sign up for that
petitions for the UN and for us to get
involved when stuff really matters and
this really matters just go look it up
I'm not gonna really get into it on the
podcast like respect again shouted
everybody also speaking of important
stuff you shout everybody who are show a
lot of support we got a lot of positive
feedback for the net neutrality episode
someone shout out all the people who
were hitting this up hitting the link
information that was what's up I'm
saying so yeah look I need oh here we
spread that gaming RunAs on the IOP and
told you what you not what you wanted
him what you needed to hear again shout
the lord de la Pole and the potentially
perfect chrome coming round table I do
want to say something before you can't
so I should probably tell them that
we're about to switch signs again thank
you sir cortical most correcting me yes
we are Matt we got probably got a couple
more episodes maybe one or two before we
will not be doing a Christmas weekend
episode we will not be doing a New
Year's weekend episode but after that
things like January 7th right low that
if we talked about it that's when we
come
back and then we will be back at our 1p
and you never know we might just jump on
just for y'all guys they're dedicated
dude just to see what you got with a
little everybody like a subscribe chat
was late make sure you subscribe to the
in a circle or media outlets we will get
the audio up later the poll go up
tomorrow all that support really helps
us and we appreciate y'all man
and on that note we owe